zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
ja es tobt ein sturm über deutschland
ein tief namens elena gut man kann sagen
ich alle teile des landes sind
gleichermaßen betroffen aber
insbesondere die nördliche hälfte hat
schon einiges abbekommen und wir schauen
uns gerade mal ein paar bilder an aus
der vergangenen nacht zum einen aus
berlin wo ein bogen gleich mehrere autos
unter sich begraben hat zum glück ist
keine person zu schaden gekommen die
feuerwehr aber musste immerhin den
ausnahmezustand ausrufen außerdem bilder
aus sachsen verkehrschaos auf den
autobahnen und auch da umgestürzte bäume
also da ist schon einiges passiert wir
blicken weiter mit euch auf die aktuelle
lage wir sprechen mit unseren
korrespondenten vor ort in berlin in
hamburg und auch im münsterland und wir
haben uns echte wetter expertise ins
studio geholt es dental geschätzter
kollege vom zdf wetter team wird gleich
bei uns auch im studio seiten zunächst
aber gucken wie er in den norden weil
den hat sie gesagt besonders betroffen
wir schalten nach hamburg zu meinem
kollegen ralf zimmermann von seefahrt 99
nach hamburg
greift - hamburg ich habe dadurch stehst
am hamburger hauptbahnhof wie man
erkennen kann wie ist denn die lage was
den bahnverkehr angeht
also die fernzüge im norden in den fünf
norddeutschen bundesländern und auch in
brandenburg und berlin ist mehr oder
weniger eingestellt worden heute morgen
sehr früh schon und ist auch nach wie
vor steht still also fernzüge gibt es
hier im grunde nicht mit denen man
hamburg verlassen kann in den norden in
den süden und eben auch im ganzen
nördlichen teil deutschlands
was im regionalverkehr angeht sieht es
ein bisschen anders aus aber
niedersachsen zum beispiel sind sehr
viele verbindungen unterbrochen auch in
schleswig-holstein und
mecklenburg-vorpommern 1 gibt es hier
etliche regionalzüge die zum beispiel
von hier aus verkehren also da muss man
sich sehr genau erkundigen wenn man
heute unterwegs sein will und muss auch
ein bisschen auf risiko spielen wenn man
unbedingt fahren will ich kann
eigentlich nur davon abraten weil wir
haben hier eine relativ große schlange
die hatte sich zwischendurch schon ein
bisschen abgebaut und ich dachte nach
scheint ja irgendwie besser zu gehen
aber jetzt ist sie wieder sehr lang also
ich glaube das wird heute nichts mehr
mit verlässlichen bahn fahren und wenn
man es unbedingt muss dann kann man es
natürlich tun das liegt natürlich vor
allem daran dass auf den strecken
behinderungen sind habt ihr gerade schon
gesagt bäume heruntergefallen sind auf
die bahnstrecken oberleitungen
unterbrochen haben und insofern wird man
das auch nicht so schnell alles beheben
können da gibt es also viele baustellen
im wahrsten sinne des wortes jetzt heute
im laufe des tages dann vielleicht schon
bereinigt werden können muss man sie ja
wir sprechen gleich kurz weiter wir
wollen vorher aber noch mal hören was
die bahn selbst dazu sagt ein sprecher
des unternehmens hat sich nämlich in
berlin geäußert die die situation
derzeit für die kunden ist
wir bitten alle reisenden die in dieser
zeit auf die reise nicht verzichten
können sich vor der fahrt manchmal zu
vergewissern auf www bahn de oder in der
app db navigator wieder zugverkehr
tatsächlich läuft wir tun alles den
aktuellen fahrplan dort so schnell wie
möglich abzubilden damit jeder weiß ob
sein zug noch fährt wir sollen auch
keine schlechte idee die reise zu
verschieben wenn man so flexibel ist wir
haben deswegen die tickets gültig
gemacht fahrkarten die für heute am
donnerstag am freitag und am samstag
gelten sie können auch noch genutzt
werden eine woche lang bis zum kommenden
samstag und die zugbindung bei unseren
sparen soll bei sparpreisen ist
natürlich aufgehoben
soweit also die bahn zu dieser situation
ralf du bist wie gesagt in hamburg und
da würde uns natürlich interessieren wie
ist denn bei euch die lage jetzt was
sozusagen das sturmtief allgemein angeht
also über diesen bahnhof hinaus da gibt
es ja noch den hafen gesetz daraus
ja die sturmflut ist ja was anderes als
der sturm also die sturmflut ist gar
nicht so schlimm heute gewesen die an
sonstigen in sonstigen wochen schon in
diesem jahr als höhere sturmfluten
gegeben aber der strom ist eben enorm
der wind ist das problem und insofern
gibt es starke beeinträchtigungen
einträchtigen auch im flugverkehr in
hamburg gegen etliche flüge heute nicht
raus am nachmittag rechnet man wieder
damit dass mehr flüge gehen aber da muss
man auch sehen wie es dann wird und hier
auch der innerstädtische verkehr also
wohl bahnverkehr autoverkehr natürlich
auch der fähren verkehr auf der elbe der
funktioniert nicht so richtig da sind
viele verbindungen unterbrochen und das
übrigens gilt auch für die ganze
deutsche nordseeküste also es gibt sehr
viele fährverbindungen die tatsächlich
unterbrochen sind auch die friesischen
ostfriesischen inseln auch die
nordfriesischen inseln und es gibt
zum beispiel auch ein kreuzfahrtschiff
das gar nicht so prima vor helgoland
kreuzen muss weil es eben nicht hamburg
rein darf also es mit passagieren an
bord ich weiß nicht wie viel spaß dann
diese kreuzfahrt noch macht heute wenn
man bei doch sehr hohem wellengang da
unterwegs sein muss das ist einfach eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme die gemacht wird um
schiffe nicht zu gefährden die dann in
die deutsche bucht reinfahren und die
elbe hoch fahren müssen um nach hamburg
zu kommen also da muss man sicher gerade
die lage heute entwickelt genau ganz
kurz noch mal vielleicht die nachfrage
war vor 60 jahren das ist ja nun ein
historisches datum vor 60 jahren gab es
die große flut werden da geht schon
irgendwie parallelen gezogen was vorhin
schon gesagt was die die flut an geht
das wäre alles noch nicht so schlimm
aber immerhin der fischmarkt glaube ich
der ist ja schon betroffen
ja aber der fischmarkt muss man sagen
ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das was
wirklich wo menschen gefährdet sind weil
dort werden immer wieder geparkte
fahrzeuge weggeschwemmt weil sie nicht
rechtzeitig weg gebracht werden das
heute zum beispiel noch gar nicht
passiert also das passiert bei anderen
sturmfluten nein die große sturmflut vor
60 jahren war ganz anders hatte einen
ganz anderen charakter kam ja auch
sozusagen ohne vorwarnung das war
eigentlich das schlimme und damals waren
die deiche vor allem das problem ist die
da ich haben damals nicht gehalten die
war nicht hoch genug für diese sturmflut
daran wird in der tat heute und wurde
gestern schon in feierstunden auch
erinnert und die menschen steckt das
noch sehr in den knochen es gibt viele
menschen die das damals miterlebt haben
diese sturmflut ist ja legendär auch
weil der damalige innensenator in
hamburg helmut schmidt hieß die man
kennt aus einem amt das er dann später
begleitet hat der große bundeskanzler
der damals diese gut gemanagt hat und ja
diese 1962 als sturmflut ist tatsächlich
heute und gestern hier passiert in
hamburg und insofern erinnert dieser
sturm der jetzt nicht annähernd so
schlimm ist aber eben auch sehr stark
erinnert an dieses historische datum
vielen dank für diese eindrücke aus
hamburg und wir hoffen natürlich sehr
mit euch dass es also dabei bleibt das
ist längst nicht so schlimm wird wie es
damals vor 60 jahren eben war dankeschön
nach hamburg ja und wir begrüssen jetzt
bei uns im studio aus der
wetterredaktion das zdf den herrliche
natur hallo hallo ist den ich ja mit was
für ein kaliber von strom haben wir es
denn da gerade eigentlich zu tun das ist
schon außergewöhnlich jetzt im februar
dass man so einen sturm hat nork antifas
durchzieht eigentlich ist der februar so
dass er ruhig ist wir haben sehr kaltes
wetter und er hochdrucklagen und jetzt
haben wir regelrecht eigentlich so
herbststürme die über uns hinweg rasen
und das ist ungewöhnlich
mit so viel wind vor allem und
flächendeckend
orkanartigen böen sturmböen ja fast
überall
ja das ist schon unüblich sage ich mal
wir haben mehrere user fragen zu denen
ich auch gerne noch mal aufrufe also
gerne kommentare und fragen wie immer an
uns über die social media kanäle oder
über e mail youtube oliver t wieso fragt
oliver thelen fragt wieso heißt es
sturmtief elena vielleicht kann man das
auch mal kurz klären wo kommen die namen
her ja die namen werden ja an der freien
universität berlin vergeben und diese
namen kann man auch kaufen ich mag nicht
zuletzt hier keine werbung machen aber
so ist das nun mal man kann sie kaufen
und dann kann man ein buch oder ein tief
entsprechend benennen lassen und linear
oder das folge der folge orkan sehr dass
diese die menschen haben halt diese
namen halt entsprechend gekauft und so
wurden sie vergeben
galant jas de fragt uns auch über
youtube wird der orkan in frankfurt am
main zu spüren sein wenn ja wie sehr wir
werden jetzt nicht alle orte durchgehen
können aber vielleicht in einer ist
damit in frankfurt ist das größte
eigentlich jetzt tue ich also in der
nähe von schauern wenn es schauer gibt
dann merkt man schon dass in der höhe
noch sehr viel wind ist das bedeutet
wenn die schauer da reinwachsen in
dieser in diesen staaten wind dann
werden die die die wird es diese werden
diese windböen nach unten gelenkt und
dann kriegen wir das so unmittelbar zu
spüren es knallt plötzlich rein und das
ist genau der hintergrund wenn gerade
kein schauer durchzieht ist der winter
eigentlich relativ moderat sag ich mal
und wird auch im westen dann allmählich
abnehmen zum abend hin und vor allem
morgen früh dann teilweise regelrecht
abflauen aber nach osten hin haben wir
es jetzt gerade noch mit sehr viel wind
zu tun also da durchaus noch orkanartige
böen zum beispiel richtung berlin und
brandenburg das zieht da noch hin und
innerhalb der nächsten stunde müssen wir
da noch mit hohen windgeschwindigkeiten
rechnen und weiteren sturmböen die erst
allmählich nachlassen zum nachmittag und
zum abend hin okay das klingt
einigermaßen beunruhigend wir reden
gleich noch ausführlicher über die
aussichten für die nächste zeit aber
berlin war gerade schon gefallen das
stichwort und da wollen wir auch hin
schalten die frage ist ob das jetzt
funktioniert leistungsmäßig für den hat
man dann doch jetzt glaube ich scheint
es zu klappen
also carsten behrendt mein kollege steht
für uns am brandenburger tor von vier
sehen zumindest für das tor steht noch
aus aber inwieweit macht sich der sturm
bei euch bemerkbar
ja vor allem in böen wir stehen hier
direkt an der straße 17 juni diese west
ost achse vom von der siegessäule bläst
sie immer wieder kräftig rüber jetzt im
moment gerade nicht auf stichwort aber
es kommt hier immer wieder dieser kalte
winter auch verbunden mit dem ein oder
anderen regentropfen direkt ins gesicht
und das merkt man schon in der nacht
hatten wir hier in der messstation am
wannsee 128 km/h das ist für berlin
schon ordentlich und die hatte der zu
beginn der sendung schon gezeigt hat ja
auch einige bäume umgehauen in
lichterfelde mehrere autos zerquetscht
waren zum glück keine verletzten die
feuerwehr seit etwa 2 uhr im
dauereinsatz und jetzt auch am vormittag
knapp 300 einsätze war so der letzte
stand denen uns die feuerwehr durch
gegeben hat also die haben gerade gut zu
tun ja genau wollte ich noch mal
nachfragen die haben den ausnahmezustand
erklärt was bedeutet das
ja ausnahmezustand bedeutet das mehr
einsätze reinkommen als im moment
einsatzkräfte zur verfügung stehen die
leitstelle muss priorisieren muss gucken
wo besteht gefahr für leib und leben wo
droht erheblicher sachschaden und dann
werden dementsprechend die nicht ganz so
wichtigen ganze dringenden notrufe
zurückgestellt und das hatten wir
gestern nacht kurz nach zwei das erste
mal dass die feuerwehr für zwei stunden
diesen ausnahmezustand ausgerufen hat
und heute morgen um 9 uhr dann erneut
der gilt aktuell auch noch also im
moment haben wir noch diesen
ausnahmezustand wegen des sturms weil
eben mehr zu tun ist als im moment
gefahren werden kann jetzt haben wir aus
hamburg gerade schon ein bisschen was
gehört zum bahnverkehr berlin natürlich
auch ein verkehrsdrehkreuz wie sieht es
da bei euch aus was zum einen den
nahverkehr angeht aber vielleicht auch
flugverkehr wie ist da momentan ist
situation
ja gehen wir mal die einzelnen
verkehrsträger nacheinander durch bei
der bahn ist es auch hier so dass der
fernverkehr eingestellt ist der
regionalverkehr ist auch betroffen dass
die strecken auch richtung brandenburg
raus die s bahn teilweise umgestürzte
bäume dadurch züge ausgebremst bei der
bvg also busse u-bahnen trams ist es so
dass die trams und u bahn die
oberirdisch fahren die fahren langsamer
40 km/h aus sicherheitsgründen damit da
nichts passiert und beim flugverkehrs es
so am ber flüge dürften starten und
landen allerdings ist das aus und
einsteigen und das beladen moment
unterbrochen also da geht im moment auch
nicht viel was das fliegen angeht auf
den straßen im umland in brandenburg
viele bundesstraßen landes straßen durch
umgestürzte bäume blockierten auch im
berliner stadtgebiet gibt es die ein
oder andere stelle auch an der
stadtautobahn wo moment die feuerwehr im
einsatz ist um bäume wegzuräumen tja
also eindrücke auch stürmischen
natürlich aus berlin waren das von
carsten behrendt wir drücken euch
natürlich auch die daumen das ist
halbwegs ruhig bleiben möge und dass
euch nichts auf den kopf fällt vielen
dank für diese eindrücke und
einschätzungen aus der hauptstadt
dankeschön nach berlin ja wie fällt die
bisherige sturm bilanz aus was unser
ganzes land angeht was deutschland
angeht boulahrouz l gibt uns noch mal
einen überblick
diese 40 meter hohe tanne hat sturm
milena umgeworfen nun drückt sie gegen
das fahr gerüst der wuppertaler
schwebebahn ein heikler einsatz für die
feuerwehr das gerüst muss möglichst
schnell wieder entlastet werden die
maßnahmen der feuerwehr besteht jetzt
darin dass wir den baum der gegen das
gerüst lehnt mit dem kran sichern und
dann langsam mit der drehleiter abtragen
entwurzelte bäume haben vor allem im
norden osten und westen deutschlands
fiel lahmgelegt die a1 etwa bei
lengerich und vor allem bahnstrecken im
norden deutschlands regionalverkehr
findet zwar statt wenn möglich doch
fernverkehr fällt in vielen
bundesländern aus vorsorglich das war
eine vorsichtsmaßnahme und das ist auch
eine lehre aus früheren situationen
dieser art extremwetter situation haben
ja leider zugenommen
wir haben die gute erfahrung gemacht
dass es besser ist züge an den bahnhöfen
zurückzuhalten wir könnten es dann viel
besser um die reisenden kümmern in
borken im münsterland waren über 50.000
haushalte bis in den morgen hinein ohne
strom weil bäume in umspannwerke
gestürzt waren auch bei b k taping stand
alles still 3 uhr ging nicht darum weg
gerade die ersten tage fertig gehabt
wenn man auf einmal stand bei dem
dunklen keine maschine lief nichts mehr
man kann nur ein paar kerzen
taschenlampen und haben wir da drei
schon qua die däumchen drehen
glücklicherweise scheint es bislang
keine verletzten oder gar tote zu geben
durch den sturm doch die gefahr ist noch
nicht vorbei an der deutschen
nordseeküste wird vor einer sturmflut
heute nachmittag gewartet
ja also das noch mal bilder aus hamburg
jetzt waren wir schon in hamburg in
berlin jetzt wollen wir noch mal gucken
ins münsterland zu meinem kollegen
thomas münten da steht er für uns thomas
und du stehst dort in einem ort borken
nämlich der besonders vom sturm
betroffen wurde erzählt doch mal was ist
da passiert
es war auch nachts um 2 uhr einfach
einen baum der neben dem umspannwerk
hier in der burgmannsstadt mittelstand
und der ist dann genau auf den trafo
gefallen und damit war in borken
stadtmitte aber auch in 23 umliegenden
gemeinden dann der strom erst mal weg
wir haben gerade schon den becker gehört
er seine probleme hatte ich war ja auch
beim metzger drin der eben sagte wir
hatten zum glück für das kühlhaus eine
notkühlung eigene notstromversorgung so
dass wir jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm
betroffen waren aber es waren auch viele
leute die heute nacht dann wach geworden
sind und sich gewundert haben warum es
dann stockfinster war die feuerwehr
relativ schnell reagiert weil sie hier
nicht so stark belastet ist und konnte
den baum entfernen das ist inzwischen
alles wieder in ordnung der strom ist
wieder da und alles läuft die ersten
brötchen gab es dann heute morgen um 8
insoweit war das nicht so schlimm was
man sagen muss ist dass man jetzt schon
wieder merkt es war ja angekündigt das
zum nachmittag hin hier noch einmal der
sturm sich ein bisschen verstärkt und
das wird schon wieder merkt es wird
etwas stärker vom winter aus wuppertal
hören wir gerade oder haben wir gehört
dass der statiker am gerüst der
schwebebahn immer wohl noch zugang her
zu drücken ob es durch diese umgestürzte
tanne da irgendwelche beschädigungen
gegeben hat wie schwebe waren selber ist
ja zum glück zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht
gefahren so dass da nichts passieren
konnte aber es gibt schon ordentlich
sturmschäden wenn das auch größtenteils
hier wirklich nur sachstände sind gerade
ist die feuerwehren uns vorbeigefahren
weil sie hier mit einer großen
drehleiter an ein haus ran musste um die
abgeknickte antenne zu entfernen und man
bereitet sich hier so langsam dann auf
dem nächsten sturm vor der heute
nachmittag hier kommen soll es ist auch
in der stadt relativ wenig los also das
wäre sonst ja normalerweise voller aber
die die zu hause bleiben können bleiben
augenscheinlich auch da ja das ist
offenbar auch vernünftig uns erreicht
gerade die meldung das ist jetzt doch
auch einen ersten toten gegeben hat im
zusammenhang mit diesem sturm ein 37
jahre alter mann ist in seinem auto
opfer des orkantiefs elena gewordenen
donnerstagmorgen gegen 9 uhr und zwar
auf der l 252 zwischen bad bevensen und
sidos und landkreis uelzen also
niedersachsen da ist ein baum auf seinen
pkw gestürzt also in der tat die
situation gefährlich thomas in ganz nrw
ist ja heute auch der schulunterricht
ausgefallen das wird die schülerinnen
und schüler hat zwar gefreut haben zeigt
aber doch auch dass die situation für
sehr ernst eingeschätzt wird bei euch
man wusste ja nicht so genau was dann
wirklich kommt es war ging ja lange
darum wie weit kommt dieser sturm von
norden richtung westen voran dass er die
energie streifen würde war ja klar aber
wie weit er dann kommen würde war unklar
und da hat man sich dann natürlich im
schulministerium gesagt okay dieses
risiko wollen wir nicht eingehen finding
ist es ja auch so wenn die kinder in der
schule sind dann müssen ja weil es eben
wenig luftfilter gibt die fenster
aufmachen und man kann man sich
entscheiden was möchte man jetzt die
fenster zu lassen wegen des sturms soll
die fenster aufmachen wegen corona
insoweit glaube ich eine vernünftige
entscheidung zu sagen wir riskieren dass
heute mal nicht eher gehen jetzt ins
wochenende so dass das nicht so schlimm
werden wird was aber auch klar ist es so
begeistert waren auch viele schüler gar
nicht dass sie schon wieder zu hause
bleiben sollen mal ganz abgesehen von
den eltern weil die diakone bedingt
sowieso schon sehr viel unterricht
versäumt haben die kitas hingegen die
kindertagesstätten sie hatten ganz
normal auf und haben auch den eltern
gesagt bitte lassen sie ihre kinder wenn
es geht zu hause aber die
kindertagesstätten in nordrhein
westfalen waren größtenteils geöffnet
und da haben die kinder natürlich dann
auch nur drinnen spielen weil man
natürlich eben nur raten kann bei dem
wetter einfach nicht raus zu gehen und
spielen die kinder schon gleich gar
nicht ja in der tat dem kann man sich
wohl nur anschließen vielen dank auch
nochmal für diese eindrücke ins
münsterland thomas münten war das für
uns danke schön und wir sprechen noch
ein bisschen weiter mit den chili als
wir haben jetzt schon einige ja doch
relativ ernste situation beschreibungen
gehört wir sind denn jetzt die weiteren
aussichten also was den tagesverlauf
angeht aber auch was die nächsten
stunden morgen auch angeht ja man muss
ja sagen es ist ja eine gefährliche
situation es sind ja orkanböen und bei
also teilweise orkanböen gewesene
orkanartige böen also 100 bis 120
kilometer pro stunde da kann man halt
nur noch schwer stehen bleiben wenn man
von so einer böe erwischt wird
und ja es schwächt sich allmählich ab
heute im tagesverlauf also lokal kann es
dann durchaus noch mal einige bühnen
geben so wie der kollege das beschrieben
habe aber als wird im tagesverlauf nun
weniger werden von westen her und auch
dann allmählich abflauen wir können uns
das auch mal auf und sagte ja anschauen
vielleicht schaltet der kollege mal
durch da sehen wir jetzt die situation
quasi heute abend und da sieht man im
westen
ich gehe mal mit dem zeiger drauf also
hier diese dunklen flächen das bedeutet
als wenig wind und man sieht einfach es
wird weniger dass es dann halt nicht
mehr stromstärke nur noch in den bergen
das was man da ruht in rot
gekennzeichnet zum vergleich dazu wie es
vorher war und wie die situation quasi
in den nächsten stunden auch im osten
deutschlands sein wird wir sehen hier da
sind durchaus noch sturmböen und
orkanartige böen dabei und du fragt es
ja wie es dann weitergeht wir haben's
morgen erst einmal dann mit relativ
ruhigen verhältnissen zu tun also auf
also am morgen freitag in köln auf
freitag in der schau mal hier in den
norden da hast du jetzt keine fast keine
farbe mehr als das bedeutet fast
windstill in den mittelgebirgen es da
schon noch etwas was gar nicht sieht man
den cursor gut ja man sieht ihn und im
süden auch und dann nimmt der wind hier
von westen her allmählich zu und dann
geht es zur sache man muss sagen dieser
dieser nächste sturm das ist ja hier
kennt stunden ist ja auch ein orkan sie
regelt von sehen wie sehr das jüngste
tief was sich sozusagen jetzt schon an
das aktuelle hiernach schließt morgen
also eine kurze ruhigere genauso
tagsüber aber dann gegen abend wieder
heftiger genau und dieses tief das ist
auch noch orkantief das hat sich
nördlich der azoren gebildet hat sich
also schön mit wärme und feuchtigkeit
angereichert und das ist quasi auch der
treibstoff von solchen stürmen und dann
landet ist quasi bei uns und über uns
das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt
liegt der jetstream derzeit mit sehr
hohen windgeschwindigkeiten wird er
quasi mit eingearbeitet und das ganze
verstärkung effekte sage ich mal und
dann bekommen wir quasi diese hohen
windgeschwindigkeiten und wenn wir jetzt
noch mal gucken das ist also abends
sehen hier etwa 17 uhr 19 uhr und da
zieht es ihn über den norden vor allem
jetzt drüber hinweg das problem ist alle
sechs stunden gibt es einen neuen modell
auf also dieses modell wird alle sechs
stunden neu gerechnet und es verschiebt
sich jedes mal wir müssen wirklich sagen
das ist jetzt ein tag vorher quasi immer
noch nicht hundertprozentig geklärt ist
wieder sturm zieht aber er scheint sehr
stark zu werden die stärke die haben wir
jetzt die ganze zeit gehabt und es
bedeutet dass der durchaus antiken
stärker sein kann als der aktuelle sturm
ja also das bestätigen auch unsere user
ich lese gerade mal ein paar kommentare
vor franzi trapp schreibt uns über
youtube vor meiner haustür sind zwei
bäume umgefallen einer davon war ein
riesiger baum einfach vom sturm
umgeschmissen andrea reichert statt uns
also bei uns in ostfriesland ist es
schon ziemlich heftig mülltonnen fliegen
durch die gegend und ein paar andere
gegenstände es ist sehr gefährlich auf
den straßen und radoslav
schreibt hiernach ist schöneres wetter
als gestern schulen hätten nicht zu
bleiben müssen ja gut okay also das mag
sein aber man weiss es halt eben vorher
auch immer nie so genau was man weiß es
nicht ganz genau aber wir wissen ja
trotzdem dass es auch ghana die gebühren
geben würde das hat ja quasi der
deutsche wetterdienst im vorfeld wir
haben sie den wetterberichten tage
vorher schon immer wieder
herausgearbeitet den aussichten also wir
wussten schon was da kommt und genauso
hat sich so ergeben wir hatten
haufenweise also nicht haufenweise aber
verbreitet sturmböen
windgeschwindigkeiten über 100 105 110
stundenkilometer das ist das ist einfach
gefährlich und ja natürlich kann man
kann man das einfach ignorieren und
einfach weiter machen aber ich denke
dadurch dass so viel und so gut gewarnt
wurde gab es ebenso wenig verletzte
sagen ich mal also dass bäume umstürzen
das kann man jetzt nicht verhindern aber
dass menschen zu schaden kommen das kann
man durchaus verhindern ja die frage
kommt dann natürlich auch immer wieder
bei solchen gelegenheiten in diesem fall
von hitzacker über youtube sind diese
stürme durch das klima wahrscheinlicher
geworden kann man das eingespannt worden
eindeutig sowieso nicht es gibt aber
verschiedene studien die die die sturm
bahn berechnen dass die sich verändern
es verändert sich die die zirkulation
auf der nordhemisphäre und da wo zum
beispiel jetzt dieses tief er kommt zur
übung da
er hat sich nördlich der erzogen und
gebildet da ist das wasser wärmer als
normal und in dieser region hat es sich
quasi mit der wärmeren
luft quasi mit den wärmeren
wassertemperaturen aufgesaugt und zieht
in unsere richtung also es gibt immer
hinweise darauf man kann nie sagen der
klimawandel ist an diesem sturm schuld
aber das ganze gefüge hat sich ja
verändert also müsste vielleicht sich
überlegen ob man diese frage eigentlich
überhaupt noch stellt weil wir leben ja
in einer veränderten in einem
veränderten klima und das verändert sich
immer weiter das ist vielleicht die
antworten darauf geben kann ansonsten
bei ganz extremen situationen zum
beispiel wie im aartal da kann man ja
auch mal darauf hinweisen da haben ja
forscher das quasi gezeigt dass das
stark mit dem klimawandel zusammenhängt
bei solchen ereignissen ist das
einfacher aber vielleicht gibt es ja
eine nachforschung nach den durchgängen
dieser zwei orkantiefs immerhin die
nacheinander durchziehen dass sich da
etwas anderes an ergebnissen ergibt
müssen wir mal abwarten also es gibt
auch einige kommentare bei uns wikileaks
im osten ist der sturm bereits zu spüren
furchtbar
und einige
die sich auch ähnlich äussern mal sehen
was sie noch bringen wird schreibt
dragee
2605 ich habe schon bammel ok offenbar
natürlich auch nicht ganz unberechtigt
wie jetzt gerade sagt also man sollte
schon aufpassen in den nächsten tagen
eine frage noch von strawberry wird die
entwicklung denn in bayern kann man ja
schon prognosen abgeben wie gesagt wir
wollen jetzt nicht jedes einzelne
gebiete in deutschland ansprechen aber
weil die frage an uns gerichtet wurde
bayern was kann man also da wird es auch
sturmböen geben davon kann man ausgehen
vor allem bayern entlang der entlang der
alpener kanalisiert sich der wind
meistens also die alpen oder dann weder
wind aus dem westen und dann gibt es
quasi kanalisierung effekte richtung
osten ziehen die böden quasi durch und
in den bergen sowieso da herrscht
weiterhin strom beziehungsweise orkan
aber hauptsächlich wird sehr
wahrscheinlich den norden definitiv
treffen da darf kaum davon können wir
ausgehen und die mitte da ist halt die
frage wie der kollege eben auch gesagt
hat wie weit kommt es in den norden in
den in die mitte und vielleicht sogar
noch teilen südens voran das ist
tatsächlich mal relativ nah vorher zu
klären vielleicht morgen in den
wetterberichten wenn wir das
wahrscheinlich deutlich genauer sein
können als heute also können wir sowieso
nur dringend empfehlen generell mit dem
wetterbericht bei uns also sowieso
gerade jetzt in den nächsten tagen
natürlich noch mal besonders wichtig
aber noch mal grob gesagt also wann wird
auch sehr nett dann vorbei sein am
wochenende ist es dann durch irgendwann
also samstagmorgen ist es noch im osten
ganz in den frühstunden dann zieht es ab
also ich rät wenn ich es ist noch da
meine ich damit die höchsten
windgeschwindigkeiten die ziehen dann in
den frühstunden quasi allmählich nach
osten hin raus und dann sind auch
sturmböen dabei also immer noch relativ
wenig und dann schwächt sich das ab und
wird dann quasi vorübergehend abflauen
doch man muss ja sagen das ist jetzt
aber natürlich auch ein bisschen weiter
geguckt am samstag kommt dann von westen
schon wieder das nächste sturmtief
nachsehen
und das wird dann da ist es jetzt nun
tatsächlich unklar wie die zugbahn ist
aber dann wird es wieder stürmisch und
wahrscheinlich ist es auch nochmal von
sonntag auf montag relativ finde hier
auch gerade in den modell könnte auch
noch mal kurz zeigen genau das ist jetzt
tatsächlich also nochmal zurück die
situation samstag also nicht morgen
abend sondern samstag das nächste
sturmtief das wird aber nach den
berechnungen hier nicht so krass wären
sage ich jetzt mal daran die nacht von
samstag beziehungsweise quatsch von
sonntag wir sehen hier den sonntag jetzt
auch wieder in rot eingefärbt mit teils
sturmböen und dann die nacht auf montag
und haben wir wieder diese violetten
flächen die unschön sind die sehr viel
wind bringen und dann geht es übrigens
auch tatsächlich bis an die alpenrand
bis nach bayern wobei ich würde dazu
noch sagen das ist jetzt zukunftsmusik
wenn wir jetzt quasi den sturm morgen
schon eingeschränkt vorhersagen können
weil je nachdem wie ihr zieht ist das
erst recht noch zukunftsmusik gut aber
trotzdem vielleicht noch mal die frage
weil in manchen bundesländern jetzt ja
auch ferien anfangen diese woche
winterferien
verhaltenstipps vom wetterexperte soll
man den urlaub absagen oder kann man
sich doch irgendwie richtung was auch
immer berge vielleicht auf den weg
machen wie sollte man jetzt gerade
richtung berge nicht da sind die höheren
windgeschwindigkeiten
aber ja es ist natürlich schwierig hier
zu sagen bleibt zu hause das ist
natürlich kann ich jetzt nicht sagen
aber man muss natürlich aufpassen
vorsichtig sein letztendlich muss das
jeder selber entscheiden aber die gefahr
besteht wir haben sie auch in den
bildern gesehen aber sturmböen oder
orkanartigen böen bäume umfallen
aber wir sehen auch es gibt teilweise
zeiten wo ist auch mal windstill ist die
frage ist nur wo fährt man dann hin weil
wir sehen auch bis montag ist es
weiterhin relativ windig
ist eine schwierige frage mit einer sehr
schwierigen antwort okay also kann man
nur sagen muss jeder für sich selber
beantworten gibt es keine ganz klare
pauschale aussage aber ist es mit
sicherheit gut auch die wie gesagt
wettervorhersagen bei uns im programm
generell natürlich zu verfolgen und sich
da schlau zu machen bevor man jetzt
irgendwie größere touren startet also
dass momentan der stand der dinge zum
wetter haben wir noch irgendwas also
noch einen hinweis wie nachgeben da du
ja sagst ergänzend dazu würde ich immer
die warnungen des deutschen wetterdienst
in mir anschauen ja amtlich ja und da
können wir vielleicht auch noch mal auf
dem bildschirm schalten hier und da
sehen wir wie sie muss man das werten
viele denken ja hier diese rutscher
vierten bereiche sind schon
unwetterwarnungen aber das sind vorab
warnungen und ich zeige dass jetzt
einfach mal exemplarisch vor was gewarnt
wird von freitag auf samstag also wieder
90 bis 100 kilo 110 kilometer pro stunde
stellen war sind auch orkanböen um 120
kilometer pro stunde aus westlichen
richtungen nicht ausgeschlossen das ist
quasi der text der quasi für orkan senat
gültig ist bei 120 km h bleibt niemand
stehen das wird einfach um wir wollen
jetzt nicht ausprobieren ist aber wie
empfiehlt es euch auch nicht das war es
von uns für den moment vielen dank ist
intelligente such bei uns im studio
danke an euch wie immer fürs mitmachen
seid vorsichtig guckt in die app cook
bei uns das wetter informiert euch bevor
ihr irgendwelche sachen draußen
unternehmen wollt dass der appell von
uns an euch danke schön und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]